Frankie said to me on the street the
other day well she's like well I'm going
to be an actress you know when I grow up
and I said okay I will support you and
help you in any way I can they know I
won't let them now I'm like you have to
be kids and grow up I the same thing
yeah MH oh so I'm I'm doing it right I
think so I do because well you were a
child actress I remember oh my gosh the
first time I saw you I just forgot about
that you came to a party you were a
child y you came to the same Elmo's Fire
party I sure did what were you doing
there and how old how old were you
probably like oh God what year did St
Elmo's Fire come out I don't know I
can't think right now I don't I don't
know we'll see um I was maybe 25 or 26 I
don't I don't I don't know Drew but you
young I was 10 oh my 1985 what were you
doing there